I have been dying for you guys to know
how disgusting this woman is she like
okay if you guys are OG blood BS you
know how Esther eats popcorn she slams
it she punches herself in the face with
the popcorn she was doing that but with
leaky saliva I was just saying but but
with like a handful and like like just
okay with it just totally fine like I'm
not vomiting I'm like do I have to have
morning sment just looking at
you if you go to getquip.com tr Tuesday
right now you'll get 20% off any
electric toothbrush mint and gum
dispenser water flosser that's 20% off
any electric toothbrush mint and gum
dispenser water flosser at getquip.com
trash Tuesday spell g t qip p.com TR
Tuesday quip the goodh habits
company okay you guys the holidays are
here and that means one thing it's time
to start shopping for the men in your
life get your boy something cute there's
no better place to look than true
classic so if you're ready to do them a
favor and upgrade his closet shop now
with our exclusive Link at true classic
tees.com TR Tuesday and save up to 60%
off sitewide during the November holiday
sale these are so soft that's true
classic tees.com
sltr Tuesday this year I'm thankful for
True classic go to drinks simply
spike.com Tuesday to find out how to get
your hands on simply spiked lemonade and
simply spiked Peach that's drinks simply
spike.com
Tuesday New York City tomorrow night
there's still a few tickets left I will
be at New York comedy club you can get
tickets at estar nights.com that's
Wednesday night the night before
Thanksgiving come party with me and my
friends and then Los Angeles finally I'm
doing a show at The Comedy Store
December 6th and um San Jose rescheduled
I'll see you guys January January 7th
and that's it I'll see you guys then
esteron ice.com for tickets yo what up
slugs Happy Thanksgiving oh my gosh I
hope you get sick eating too much food
um I will be in Houston Texas at the
Houston Improv December 15th and 17th
I'll be in Edmonton at the comedy strip
January 12th through 13th I'll be in
Jacksonville Florida January 19th and
20th come on Florida you know we know we
know how to party together Denver
Colorado February 16th and 17th and then
in uh DC at the comedy Loft March 22nd
23rd a lot of d keep being added I also
have a monthly show at The Comedy Store
the next one will be December 21st I
think so please keep checking my website
and my Instagram Annie letter.com shows
and you can see me every Thursday on ANW
love you
guys what's the problem Master
well that's one way to set this up this
should we talk about it I think we
should okay let's do it I actually don't
think we should I take that back but I
can't not anymore well let's start off
with the wardrobe malfunction that isn't
a malfunction it's actually a blessing I
just can't with these breasts that I've
grown um I
don't they're just why have they
grown why are they growing so
fast um I am currently
pregnant don't but honestly stop it's
just stop right there
okay um yes I have been I guess I've
been keeping a little secret a little
naughty girl but I can't really keep it
secret anymore because the
stomach the uterus they're just I you
know what I watched myself on that
Angela White episode last week and was
like oh this is not hiding I could tell
I could not tell when I watched it on
camera I was like there's something
going on in there do you think maybe you
just have pregnancy eyes that you're
looking at yourself because you know
this information maybe but also it was
either announced this or people are like
secretly like Esther is really having a
good holiday season she's G which by the
way I wish to God more than anything I
was having a pregnancy where I could
just Chow Down and party time and like
Live It Up not at all I've had like
debilitating acid reflux so I haven't
been able to enjoy food but I did just
yesterday start a prescription ant acid
so I might be chowing down now can I
tell you guys what it was like the first
couple weeks of
Esther pregnant she would FaceTime me
and I'm not kidding you I don't know if
you just started producing like all too
much
saliva remember that and you would have
to have a towel or a napkin cuz you if
you didn't like spit into it you would
just start like drooling on the side
you're foaming at the mouth basically
which I no one had warned me that that
was a pregnancy symptom and I still
don't know if it is I think it was a
nausea symptom because you know how you
foam in the mouth before you when you
get nauseous I I attributed it to like
an acid reflux thing where I was just
producing so much also I mean there's so
much to say and it's all negative um no
I'm I'm grateful obviously it's so
beautiful it's a beautiful thing um but
it has been I'm just going to be I'm
keeping real it has been so challenging
as you guys everyone here knows so
Whitney lied Whitney lied Whitney this
is my headline Whitney and I are having
very different pregnancies cuz she
didn't even notice the first 10 weeks we
just had her on tiger belly and she was
like I didn't feel a thing which is cuz
those were the hardest I remember worst
I I'm not I'm not kidding you guys like
she projectile vomited on FaceTime
though also those recordings where I
can't remember like the handmaid's Tale
episode that we recorded I was so sick
that day remember I was barely
functioning and yes there was one of my
most memorable vomit moments in the
first trimester I'm just so people know
I'm like halfway through right now I'm
like probably around 5 months pregnant
right now four and a half five months
and we just had like a good 20 week scan
yesterday so I'm happy about that um but
it's I've had because I've had pregnancy
loss before I had a miscarriage two
years ago the fear like never goes away
so that's also why I haven't wanted to
talk about it because I'm Like Anything
could happen and that's still the case
anything can happen but I'm just like
you know what that's life and we'll deal
with whatever comes our way we love
donut we'll we'll be okay no matter what
um but one of my most memorable
vomits was a night where I was laying in
bed Dave was out playing poker which
he's been doing my whole pregnancy he's
also been driving you around passenger
princess I know he drove you to the
Taylor Swift
concert you don't forget anything no
because Jean called me and I was like
what are you doing he's like oh I got to
meet Dave at the casino cuz he's driving
Ester to the concert I was like oh which
I never get that like that's not our
relationship but pregnancy I'm getting
the relationship I've always
wanted I'm receiving love for two is
like forget eat for two receive love for
two that's like the whole that's the
most the best part um but there was a
night where I was I'll just this night
will like I will never forget this night
I was laying in bed and I felt it was
starting to get hard to breathe there
was a heaviness in my chest and I had I
have never experienced that in my life
and that was a very new thing for me
even in pregnancy I was like this is
scaring me it's hard
I'm and it's hurting and of course
what's the the first thing I do I
FaceTime Kila I don't call 911 I'm going
to be of any help if you're having
anything serious happening but it is
funny like how the comfort of someone
you know who went to nursing school is
better than
911 like did it ever occur to you that
nursing school was a Whole Decade ago
and maybe I don't remember you're up to
date I swear you're so up to date you
know so much like you you're so humble
about it but you have like medical blood
like you're like reading medicinal
journals on the side like you know I
trust you especi the when we first
bonded was when I was on a standup tour
in Australia one of my uh or in New
Zealand one of my uh lymph nodes was
swollen and one wasn't I texted you that
whole I barely knew you we had just this
was 10 years ago we just met and you
knew everything what to do like I was
like augmented yeah and I I feel like
not I hope it's not offensive but like
you're my on demand nurse that's how I
fell in love with you so not qualified
by the way if it's something I can't
answer then I'll ask my sister and
that's how it's filters it so my sister
is a final word because I'm like hey is
this correct and she's like yeah tell us
you never pretend to know things you
don't you always like the first to be
like I don't know looking you you tell
me where to go anyways I didn't help you
this time though well okay so I was like
it was a heaviness I was struggling to
breathe I FaceTime you
and I'm like Kila like I I I'm having a
hard time breathing and you're just kind
of looking at me like sad and then
within 4 seconds I'm like I got to go I
get up off the FaceTime I run to the
bathroom and I don't make it there I
just vomit all over the all over the
bedroom floor violent painful acidic the
vomit is red I didn't eat anything red
it wasn't blood um and so that was like
probably the most and then that night
also Whitney was vomiting too in Long
Island and so we face you guys are
tethered so I after that then I FaceTime
you and I was like okay I just vomited
that must have been the most
relieving thing to just be like okay
that was that you can connect the dots
it feels good was it does but it was
such a traumatic vomit I know I remember
it probably came out your
nose oh no it what you don't have you
haven't you haven't had a traumatic
vomit if it's not coming out from
everywhere you have you ever double
dragoned what are you talking about or
you're vomiting and [__] at the same
time what are you talking about Annie I
need Annie for the Double
Dragon she heard I need Annie for my
Double Dragon reference is that like a
phrase if there's anyone who knows who's
had who's Double Dragon before I know
it's no I double dragon I triple Dragon
but I do remember that and I do remember
looking at you and thinking like oh you
look not
nauseous like you know you don't usually
you know like there's usually that's not
visual but it is you were like a little
bit gray or green I was like oh she's
not well and you were foaming at the
mouth like a rabid dog I was like uhoh
she's going to blow that was a bad night
I've had some violent vomits and I've
had some baby vomits some just like spit
up ones thankfully now that I'm in like
the second trimester I'm not vomiting
but I'm this is my headline about the
second trimester where everyone's like
oh this is like the time to shine like
you're going to be a glowy goddess
you're going to feel so much energy no I
would say it's better but I'm not good I
do think you you are very very pretty
Happy
Thanksgiving guys oh my God
Randy oh my God the pregnancy has been
revealed I just found out Esther's
pregnant from the back I knew something
was up we've been keeping it a secret
from Annie can you imagine I would be so
livid if this found out we're also going
to have like congratulations we're so
excited you guys know now and she's
allowed to chew gum whatever the [__]
she wants but say it into the mic wait
what did you say going to have like a
proper baby shower yeah yes of course
are you kidding me let's have three
thank you because I will not have one if
I don't do it here on this show well I
will say something too I had a dream
that you were also pregnant and I was
actually pissed I was like guys I feel
like you're putting pressure on me a
little
disrespectful wait a second though are
you if
I I don't know I don't want to be told
don't tell me guys I mean until my I'm
going to be the like rigid [__] dried
up [__] on the show with these two
juicy pregnant women you're fertile am
also you have um healthy embryos
confirmation from a doctor I actually
doing great guys sorry guys I actually
am doing great I'm more fertile than her
I actually think in the last year why is
it a competition in the last year listen
it's life baby you got three [__]
together we're going to we're going to
compete in the last year and a half I
feel like my body's definitely changing
like I have this fear that I'm in like
per menopause I think you're not but I
also had that fear really yeah I think
you just need to get all the tests I got
and they'll tell you the same thing you
look juicy doesn't she look juicy she
does I don't want to like I feel weird
that we're relying on looks for
fertility but I also do think there's
some truth to it and also you've gotten
pregnant not no offense so many times
yeah no offense you've really HED up in
there you've gotten pregnant you've
parted but wouldn't wouldn't it make
sense that the Universe wouldn't give me
one now because no it's not how that
works no okay maybe that's why you are
feeling these things you're having
you're having um baby guilt but I'm not
having maybe maybe but that that always
enters your mind right like even if
you're so pragmatic and so Progressive
about your ideas about abortion there is
always that feeling at least for me
where you're like [__] like like what if
that was my only chance like I'd be
lying if if I said you know I didn't
think of those things I think that's a
very normal thought to have and it would
almost be weird if you didn't have like
these weird afterthoughts about having
abortions and stuff like even me this
whole time since my miscarriage two
years ago I've been like that was never
a baby like I've had no attachment to it
but even now I get a I'm like oh what if
what if you know so I think it's just
normal any pregnancy loss whether
elective or not like there's going to be
it's we're just animals but wait it's so
exciting you're pregnant I've been dying
I've been you guys miss the trimester
that was the most disgusting and make
fun of all I have been dying for you
guys to know how disgusting this woman
is she like okay if you guys are OG
blood BS you know how Esther eats
popcorn she slams it she punches herself
in the face with the popcorn she was
doing that but with leaky saliva I was
just saying but but with like a handful
and like like just okay with it just
totally fine like I'm not vomiting I'm
like do I have to have morning sickness
just looking at you and it's like and
it's funny because Whitney's like that's
not a symptom which it is a symptom I
know it's a symptom but it's so funny
Whitney's like that's not even a symptom
Whitney thinks Esther's completely made
up any like hard pregnancy things and I
don't blame her it's for some reason
it's just magical on her it was going to
happen this way for you and it was going
to happen this way for her Annie you
came in with quite the look today guys
well I wanted them okay this was the
plan and I I you guys you absolutely
rule I want to just give shout outs and
thankfulness to this new production team
you guys are unbelievable we love you so
much I feel carried and held by you I
said last minute I said I would like to
dress like a pilgrim and show up as a
pilgrim without them knowing and like
have a pilgrim reveal to overshadow your
pregnancy reveal but they couldn't get
it together in time so this is what they
came up with instead which seems true
seems good good I love that but wouldn't
have been funny if I came up like waist
up in Pilgrim that would be actually hot
we should have done that maybe the boobs
but I asked him like last night wait can
we see also the baby you have okay my
boy has been sick so he's coming with to
work with Mommy wait what's going on he
it's been a series of unfortunate events
for my poor Randy was it a UTI he had a
UTI that was part of it so first he had
fleas and they gave him the the oral
medicine which is not meant for a little
baby he's an innocent little boy he's
not supposed to be swallowing flea
medicine wait really so he had a
horrible not it turns out but he's just
a little precious boy he's shouldn't do
anything that's he's got a low immune
system obviously he's born with M you're
like already a you're a mom I am a mom I
am a mom but I'm telling you after my
iasa thing I'm like really like poor
Todd I'm like no more hot fries in the
house we ain't eating snacks from the
I'm like this can't happen we can't be
I'm not having a junk food child I know
we already have one in the
family you're like feeding it onions
already just up this is he's not moving
he's listen he's always been a floppy
docile lover but he's he's very um this
is Esther in bed um just kidding she'd
be perched her ass up but anyway um
that's for you guys to see in her
set but he I think he's just he's on a
lot of antibiotics oh okay he looks so
but he is always flbe Jesus do you think
he'll yeah he looks like he's resting in
peace yeah he looks like an maybe an old
lady that he loves his bag too this was
[Music]
the oh my God he's my
prince I have to say you look good in a
baby
carrier this she's trying to curse me
with a baby I know and it really is a
curse like that's the thing is I don't
want to talk people out of pregnancy
maybe take his little thing off oh it's
okay
oh oh he's stranger danger he's so cute
he's a good boy he's like I have to know
her oh it's Mommy oh my God it's
actually he has two speeds yeah hyper
crazy Zoomies and oh my God he wants to
he want a baby he's eating my baby he
wants he's hungry that was a big joke
early on we were like joking that donut
would be like I accidentally ate the cuz
it's so little oh my God he smells your
snatch he SMS pull up can we pull up
chanuk I mean since come here baby what
this is just one other thing you have to
be um afraid of during pregnancy it's c
h cat poop no it's a it's a a baby Thief
isn't there cat poop you're like
not toxoplasmosis yeah is that not a
vote for dogs vote dogs Ru vote for dogs
dogs Rule no it's sorry oh my God I
swear I've had so many weird like weepy
little I'm so excited our baby's having
a baby Kila I know this this this feels
both strange but also incredible but the
the whole toxoplasmosis thing or at
least I learned in microbiology class it
can cause like mental illness down the
road like if you're exposed yeah if you
have like an outdoor cat and then the
mother gets exposed to like a protozoan
like TOS toxo
plasma you have to not Garden not go
near cat litter not cook clean or wipe
your butt it's really hard here's here's
a something I want to scare you about
okay oh she's not easily SC it's a
Filipino it's a Filipino um monster
called Baba a Filipino monster Baba and
then there was a thing I would never say
because that's really not a good word
wait how is Maybe I'm Wrong about this
chuk is like baby demon right what is
the one that steals babies you're asking
me we'll get back to it tap into your
Asian make it happen oh he looks cute so
cute he looks a little bit like Dave
Esther Dave mixed together now do you
think I think your kid's gonna be cool
and I know that it's against some odds
he needs you got to bring this baby over
to me for
like once every three
months I got this i got this I'm going
to make this baby for a scary sleepover
wait okay actually did you guys ever
have sleepovers or hang out with your
mom's
friends what wait I I know it does sound
crazy but I'm like trying to like think
wait what do you mean I brought this up
to Dave and he was like what are you
talking about I would I like would
occasionally go have a sleepover at my
mom's friend's house wasn't this just
them babysitting you this was your mom
okay this is your mom calling her
friends and being like help me with this
child but I I'm going to lose my mind
this was like a postp part of like
support group right and then calling it
a sleepover so it wouldn't hurt your
feelings I think I wanted to do it I
think I was like oh that would be I
think I was the ring leader I had women
my mom's age that my mom's friends would
like take me place on excursions okay so
similar it was like a like a cool older
person that's it's kind of really fun I
went to Longwood Gardens can you look up
Longwood Gardens to show them this
beautiful Philadelphia haunt I have a
question Esther do you think you're
going to dump Annie and I cuz we're not
moms and you're going to find your own
we dump the moms the moms moms get
dumped you think yeah yeah I do I'm
ready I'm getting my last little looks
in
I think it is a that's beautiful I think
it is a real it's not that good to look
at sorry it's that's where my Michel muu
and this this this this DJ that my mom
used to work with used to take me here I
think this is a very real like women in
your 30s like conversation of when
certain friends have kids and certain
ones don't it's kind of impossible to
like keep it up the same way that it was
like I've I struggle with that with
friends who have kids right I think it's
you're on a different pace but it's it's
for me like it's a little more selfish
it's like I when my friends had kids
when I was still very worried about my
fertility and didn't have Todd and like
wasn't sure if I was going to be able to
have kids it was very confronting and
when I was around the baby I would which
was pretty selfish like I wasn't able to
just kind of like celebrate them and
their children it was more like oh my
God [__] like what does this mean for me
am I not going to be able to like when
you told us about your other pregnancy I
was like [__] you got pregnant on me
like I was like that selfish I get it
though like cuz I when I when you hear
someone is pregnant you're like oh my
God I'm going to lose them to their
child it's real it's definitely
relatable I also have but I beat that
baby didn't I that one wasn't a baby I I
feel like when friends have kids because
I was a babysitter for so long I wanted
I kind of I'm like not as interested cuz
I'm like I know that at one point that's
going to be my whole life again and
previously that's like a job to me and
so I have not been that friend that like
wants to hang with the kids I have to
admit I don't know that might make me an
[__] but that's just my reality I
think it's just a very as a woman
motherhood is just the topic in general
is very tense so it's just like things
happen and it's like I was talking to my
friend Abby because I haven't spent that
much time with her kids and they're you
know they're like grown kids now they're
so cute and I was like I really want
like hang with you she's like yeah I
think You' really like them she's like
it's my fault though cuz I'm selfish
like I want you to myself I don't want
to be like mothering when I'm with you
like so we always end up like she gets a
babysitter and we go out like there's a
lot less but I was thinking I was like
we should go to the beach and stuff and
hang out with the kids because I love
being around kids that is true because
when um I hang out with my friends who
have children who have two three kids
we're not talking at all I'm just
entertaining the kids especially if we
go to the beach then it's like all
activities right like everyone is
handson like everyone hands on deck
because there's children that we need to
care for like collectively yeah or
you're the friend who's not hands on
deck which I've been the Auntie like I
remember my brother getting so mad at me
cuz they had all their babies like in
the pool everyone was like playing with
the babies and stuff and I was
sunbathing in like a bikini he was like
Annie I was like all right you're right
you're right right but it is it becomes
all about the the kids and that can be
hard when you're that's not the place in
your life that you're at exactly it's
hard for me to reconnect one of my best
best um friends he's a dad of three and
even though it's like we should be
making time for each other and we do
there isn't a whole lot of conversation
really between us it's just hanging with
the kids I know people like a lot of
people like I won't post too many
pictures of my kid on here what I'm like
post your babies I want people to like
love their kids and share their kids and
you know what so okay I for a long time
bless you you guy you [__] it's
going to come in stronger now you're
going to S you know I sneeze in twos and
you just she did stole two sneezes I was
like kind of evil to my face did you see
it I like okay so I'm definitely not a
girly who's been like motherhood I want
kids like I dreamed of my wedding day
not at all like I I always thought if I
had kids 40s what maybe who knows like
and in the last few years you know I
obviously made the decision two years
ago to try to get pregnant then after
that pregnancy loss it wasn't like oh
let's get going again it was like well
wait a minute is this what we want and
we had lots of conversations that were
like we'll be okay either way and you
know what really sold
me and I know this not a lot of people
will agree but one of my girlfriends
Grace was like you know she has two kids
and I was like I still don't you know I
had the pregnancy loss we don't know and
she was like you know you could just
have one
kid and and I was like I never thought
about that I always thought zero or two
you know and once she said that
something clicked for me like maybe one
maybe is like the chill dip your toe in
it's never going to get too crazy I know
it'll still be really hard but that's
where I'm at right now I'm really
romanticizing I have a counter okay you
want the second one so the first one can
help raise it and then which your sister
did for you and but you also want to be
careful I have a friend who is in her
50s and she's her son just turned 15 and
she's like she had a kid way earlier too
and she's like I have been driving
children around for 25 years cuz you
have to drive them everywhere yeah or
you get them a Town Car let's just a
Town Car get more ads up on
this bing bing bing bing bing no but
have you ever seen like the rich kids
that like pop out of like a black car
and you're like oh my God movies I have
only seen them in movies too they do end
up getting kidnapped they are always
kidnapped and held for ransom um the
sweetest most considerate man I ever
dated was an only child really I have a
lot of only children in my life there's
some positive research about only
children and I know some people get mad
they're like that's selfish they'll be
and I know there's challenges like when
they don't have a playmate I get that I
know there's like downsides and I know I
also could change my mind later but
right now in this moment I'm very
committed and love the thought of a one
and an only my dad was an only child I'm
like half only child and also the
positive research is like only children
tend to be more creative more confident
in their ideas I don't know why more
imaginative whatever attention yeah it's
a lot of attention you're getting all of
your needs met because it's not being
this but it's also a lot of alone time
it is learning how to be alone alone in
your room my sister's partner for the
past decade is an only child and he's
great he's great is that the lover the
lover who's lover I'm just saying did
you date him first you're like he's the
kindest only child oh God gross gross
gross gross um pass the Baton yeah but I
remember him being like treating me like
I think it's because he was really close
to his mom and his mom was a little
older and needed a lot from him so he
was just really good about fixing things
and always like caring for a woman um
and so that kind of transferred over to
me for a couple years and he was really
great did you just have an image of a
child taking care of you yeah fixing
things that's just sweet that's just
sweet get to work kiddo I yeah I'm
definitely I want to become the advocate
for one one child household China China
China I'm coming for you I'm going to be
the F actually they I heard they lifted
that they lifted it and that no people
still don't have more than one they
don't want to be the weirdo in the
neighborhood it's like it's funny how
that like cultural it just it's hard to
change that even you know what I mean so
here's the thing like when when I used
to Foster single puppies it was the
hardest thing ever and then when you
would have two then they'd play with
each other then they wouldn't be nipping
at your ankles all day but then it's
like well what's the difference between
two and 10 so then I would just Foster a
whole I would let you Rey examine me
just by the way the straightness to
which you throw that finger up it's a
gorgeous finger it's so clean it's so
precise look ooh thin she did like a
cute little red rum too double jointed
well I might come when you're doing it
if you keep doing that but yeah no I do
feel like of course there's major
benefits to having more than one like
for sure everyone you know everyone
loves a sibling I get it um but it does
seem like the people you know who have
kids like life is peaceful with one and
then to it's like oh how you been I
think you have to worry about getting
too a meshed with them too though if you
just just have one oh two best friends
that's where I'm that's my goal in fact
let's keep space uh I'm called mother
and that's all we need to have Trisha on
obviously again but I saw her on like
she was talking to some girl on the
podcast about how the girl like sleep
trained her baby from day one and she's
like where does your baby sleep and
Trisha's like oh she sleeps in bed with
us and I was like yes Trisha like she's
my motherhood goal however you do it is
the correct way right like there's so
many people with so many opinions and so
just snarky and disgusting on the
internet about like the proper way to be
a mom it's like dude like I grew up in
the Philippines co- sleeping is a real
thing and there are benefits to co-
sleeping that I think that maybe you
know people here are not like you know
whatever it is whatever it is however
you do it keep the baby alive it's all
good I think you just don't want your
baby like getting its period in your bed
you know what I mean it's like I think I
just when they need some privacy they'll
let you know they'll be
like oops I should have put a maxi pad
on yeah I I love that you say that and I
feel the same way it's like come judge
me like I you can't penetrate my like
Fortress of not giving a [__] what other
people think yeah also it's so like
elitist right and it's because it's like
not everyone can have a separate bedroom
for the baby or have a separate crib
it's like there are families that sleep
in one room who who we have one crib for
the parent and the kid adult crib baby
crib do you know what I mean so it's
like dude sometimes co- sleeping is the
only way also if you intuitively feel
like that is what's good for your family
then you should intuitively do that yes
I also do want to come forward and be
very clear that I'm halfway through this
pregnancy and I have not bought a single
baby item I've not done a lick of
research I have no Nursery like I am
really just hoping that at the 11th Hour
that inspiration will come but I'm like
I think I'm in denial I think my guess
is that you went through a very
traumatizing miscarriage that was really
important that you disassociate it from
it to survive I'm guessing I think that
like any anytime you have pregnancy loss
it doesn't ever leave you and so every
doctor's appointment I literally go in
like shaking I'm so nervous that it's
going to be that bad news and then when
I leave and it's it goes well I'm like
oh my God Dave she's still there I'm
like can you believe it he's like yeah
like for some reason it didn't stick on
him the way it stuck on me where and I
think this is a thing like pregnancy
after loss you're just yeah that never
leaves you you're almost like afraid to
celebrate anything yes but I think now
I'm 20 weeks and I'm
like okay like whatever's going to
happen is going to happen and I should
probably get a little bit ready well
well but I mean I have friends and also
it's totally okay to not feel completely
connected to your pregnancy I I have
friends who didn't even feel connected
to their baby when their baby was born
like it took a it took
to kick and that happens and that's also
okay like however it you know happens
for you if you start to feel like oh
crap I got to start nesting you know
whenever that hits you is whenever it'll
hit you but I don't think you know what
I mean like as long as you're not going
to throw your baby in a dumpster I think
it's okay I think I mean it's timeline
thank you for saying that I me I was
thinking about the dumpster no um just
kidding thank you for being believing in
me not maybe a dumpster I did hit that
second trimester and that's like when
you're supposed to get all this magical
energy to like make a nursery and that's
like when me and Dave went to Vegas like
baby moon until the last second if you
want who cares do whatever you want it's
like it's fine you're Dave will do it
just make Dave do it but also I was
thinking maybe we do like a vlog and we
help you put together your Nursery I
will take anything that you offer yeah
please I have a friend who makes all um
I think I told you about him my friend
Johnny he does all of the like baby
furniture and stuff let's get it going
let's I guys any recommendations
anything I I'm starting from scratch
eser even the way that you did this
announcement was crazy like we had a
whole show planned and you're just like
I'm going to just cavali like coming in
it's now or never I think I couldn't no
I woke up I looked at the stomach and
was like it's not a
burrito after I'm going I've eaten a lot
I'm like do have a bump it's so cute
thank you you have been very supportive
of believe that it's a bomb that is so
funny cuz last week after we recorded
you came out of the bathroom and Annie
was like exactly you said you're like oh
my God you have a bump and you're like
no I ate too much and
you're there is that phase though and
I'm still in it where it's you don't pop
yet and you just look like a pillow I
keep saying she she's my weight
now you're my regular weight we can show
clothes we'll shorten the legs and you
can wear around my waist but I do not
want to be like moving into Mommy Mode
24/7 like I really look anything can
happen but I I want to still be me you
will be my friend Meg has four young
kids all under the age of like nine four
eight just four young kids I seeing
double over here she's like my number
one like com like we go to concerts
together like any time like hey you want
to do this she's like I'm down she's the
most fun she completely does not buy
into the oh I got to stay home and be
out she's like [__] that I'm enjoying my
life I know that you are not into this
idea but I would just be like build an
addition and bring the parents bring
those old ass parents over and let them
enjoy rais not that's actually I think
that the millennial myth is we all think
our parents are going to be so helpful
there's so many things I read on Reddit
and people I know that are like so my
parents come by they're not helpful they
don't do anything your mom does
everything though don't forget that she
could definitely clean some bottles she
could be doing all of the stuff that's
not the actual mothering yeah and your
dad will be entertaining you I don't
know what the my Dad's reaction was like
I'm too young to be a grandfather I'm
like you're 80 sir you're 80 my Dad's
reaction was um yeah he was like
Esther's going to be the first mother
that needs to be
incubated he he's a fan of the show he
gets he knows the tropes he knows our
roles
that is so funny but I think it is like
that is the bummer of having older
parents in this situation because it's
like it would be awesome to just have
some young ass parents whiping and just
raise our children for us the other
thing that I've thought about a lot is
I'm like damn I have to I wish and I
don't really wish this but I think to
myself I wish I had gotten pregnant at
18 and I'll tell you why because at 18
you're young and you're stupid and
you're so used to new experiences in
life like life throws you all these
crazy things and you just you're you
just assume that's how it's supposed to
be but at 35 like I know what life is I
know what I can eat I know what I can't
I know how I'm comfortable how I'm not
so to get thrown all these new changes
like I'm resisting also when you're 18
you'll definitely go clubbing when you
have a kid you're like Mom take this
baby can I retire as your on call nurse
and give you the number of two of my
best friends who are pediatric nurses
yes okay have them final isses out are
they available to move in do they live
in yes possibly we need to get a Night
Nurse for the baby and a day nurse for
you I know just to make sure you have
your
electrolytes dude also the worst part of
the first trimester was like a a feeling
I'll never forget is being so thirsty
but water having an aversion to water
where like I couldn't drink water it
would make me throw up it was so
disgusting but I was thirsty I've never
seen a more disgusting weeping hot mouth
at the same time oh like a m can you
imagine being thirsty and you can't
drink and it's right there it was to I
it was just can you imagine watching a
person just leak like goo from their
mouth I was like ew is that the mucus
cork that's how you know up so
comfortable with you guys that I would
just lay there like I know I'm like do
you want to adjust your chin a little
bit like do you want to like look a
little cute for us it's disrespectful to
a point I know you and Whit am I your
nurse like what you and Whitney always
say to me you're like oh God I know like
Jesus she's like in the corner I'm like
why are Whitney's tits perkier than your
face come on pick it up Whitney looks so
pretty pregnant I know it's actually the
most annoying thing I've ever seen but
we all knew this we all saw this coming
I'm excited for yours to like really
round out this belly the other thing
also I was a FaceTiming with Whitney the
other day and she's you know like eight
and a half months pregnant she's like I
just you know started the lower back
pain I'm like I've had that for 2 months
already like I had it before I was
pregnant that's how I got pregnant I was
laying down on my
back is the baby going to have a seap oh
my God that would actually be so cute a
tiny baby seap that would be cute was it
something you guys planned or I don't
know if I'm allowed to ask this yeah you
can ask we I you know like I said after
the miscarriage cuz I had a type of
miscarriage where I couldn't try for six
months and then after that six months I
was
like I lost the taste for wanting to do
that again cuz it was so hard and so I I
think like a year and a half I was like
or two years whatever I was just like I
think I want to but I don't want to it's
so hard and it sucks and I like getting
high and you know I was getting in shape
and then at the beginning of this year I
was just slowly warming up to it and
then in the spring I was like let's kind
of try a little bit
and it really for me wasn't until it's
those ovulation that those strips so
crazy literally like I cannot physically
get pregnant without those I thought I
was like oh I I know I no I don't know
my cycle at all I get the ones with the
they give you a little smiley face when
you pee on them that got both times I
got pregnant in a second which they
should give you like ones for whether
you're trying to get pregnant or not it
should be a frowny face or a smiley face
she yeah it's like pink or blue Bobby is
not allowing me to get pregnant yet what
yeah no in my dream I was like this is
going to be a wild tiger belly no he's
he's
like he's like straight up like I'm not
there yet I'm I can't handle you being
in a serious relationship and please
don't get pregnant no sorry Bobby sorry
Bobby you know what also there's been
some things that you've told me about
your guys' post relationship
relationship that I was like that's fine
you're such a good and then I tell Dave
and he's like boundaries are being
crossed and
boundaries and so this I'm red flagging
that you need and I also get pregnant oh
God Annie come on just give me like a
year or two please Annie when I get
pregnant you'll be the first phone call
and I'm like get to work get to work
we're doing this well okay in IAS I
don't know if I said this before I
really had like vision of like cuz I'm
so afraid to have sex and I'm like why
do I have so such a funny but it is
because I am I'm like I always have so
much anxiety and it's because I'm so
[__] fertile I'm like such a mom you
really are though I'm like so like oh
God I get knocked up at any moment like
we have like we're having a baby sex
every time I [__] him it's like an I'm
like Todd stop but pulling out works I
know and it has worked but it's still
scary you know what thank you for saying
that pulling out work
promise it does get I know we're
supposed to be teaching young girls
things or maybe not but like I am sorry
but it [__] works it has worked for
me my whole life I have never gotten
pregnant I've only done pull out
obviously safely with safe Partners but
like and I think maybe it does the
partner needs to be good at it but if
you're if you two I know I don't want to
be like rude I do not trust Todd I do
not trust him he is Young he's
young I do not trust this PO game it's
work so far but I mean maybe you're
right maybe some people's pull out game
I just haven't been with anyone who's
pull out game as week it's always a guy
who's like very he pulls out and then he
still has to jerk himself off for like
20 seconds before he comes yeah right
that's I I'm not supposed to give too
much information about my sex life but
I'll just nod my head yeah there's good
pull out game out there and very
considerate pullout game yeah and when
you're like wait did you get out before
that first burst o you're like is that
you or me down
there who's wet spot is this you [__] no
that and that is that fear is so real I
told you I basically only [__] about
my period because I'm like I don't trust
you it's so funny that it's teacher go
to I need to go to a school it's so
funny I don't trust myself it's myself
no you have a fetish though I don't have
that fetish do not I'm like I want to be
able to get to the tip of my head or
tissue cute outfit look at this B oh my
God our sexy social media [__]
I don't want to waste all of this
Thanksgiving Decor what do we have going
on here so selfish you stole
Thanksgiving well my child with your
turkey my body oh it looks so cute I
took hot picks of her thank you can we
do a shoot where we do like a mold of
your stomach and where somehow involved
and your mold you know how people do
like molds of their their belly that's
repulsive but it's like our hands on it
and not Dave's I like that wait do
people still do um um belly molds yeah
what's the purpose again I think so they
can have a weird they can fill it in
with plaster and have like a weird their
own stomach with their husband's hands
on it that is the scariest thing I if I
saw that in your house I'd run out I
want to motivate crowning
e I'm putting it over my
door nothing is worse for me than when
my mouth doesn't feel clean it's also
worse for me it's really bad for
everyone I said fire close to her quip
the toothbrush the water floss
have changed my mouth forever like and I
love how Chic the toothbrush actually is
I love showing it off it's like so cute
and like do you have to show people look
Eye Brush look Eye Brush I'm proving
this guys she wouldn't have gotten
pregnant if it wasn't for quip I do love
that it has timed Sonic vibrations with
30 second pulses to guide a dentist
recommended 2-minute clean it's
lightweight Sleek design reusable
Handles in a range of sleek metal Hues
as well as bright plastic colors to just
pop whatever your bathroom counter Vibe
is if you go to getquip.com
Tuesday right now you'll get 20% off any
electric toothbrush mint and gum
dispenser or water flosser that's 20%
off any electric toothbrush mint and gum
dispenser water flosser at getquip.com
TR Tuesday spelled
gq.com TR Tuesday quip the good habits
company always such a pain in my butt to
have to shop for guy and I am so
thankful that true classic exists I
would like to spread this on bread this
feels so soft Todd wears these all the
time this is such a good boyfriend tea
where like you actually end up stealing
it and right now for a limited time this
November they're giving our listeners a
special Black Friday deal all month long
up to 60% off sitewide that's so good at
true
classic% yes 60% off sitewide at true
classic tees.com sltr Tuesday and honest
sluggy like this is the boyfriend gift
also men tend to wear the same clothes
every day like they need some help so if
you're ready to do them a favor and
upgrade his closet shop now with our
exclusive Link at true classic tees.com
trash Tuesday and save up to 60% off
sitewide during the November holiday
sale these are so soft that's true
classic tas.com
sltr Tuesday this year I'm thankful for
True classic and I'm telling you guys
simply spiked is so freaking delicious I
enjoyed it over the summer but now it's
the one thing I bring to all of family
parties everyone loves it they have so
many great flavors I know that like as
soon as I get an invitation to a holiday
party I will be bringing simply spiked
Peach because it's real juice that they
it's so it's a crowd pleaser and what I
love about it is if you don't want just
one flavor you can pick up a variety
pack and the variety pack is everything
from the lemonade strawberry lemonade
blueberry lemonade and watermelon
lemonade all of the lemonades basically
plus they have their signature ones the
Peach um the Kiwi Peach all of the
peaches as well go to drinks simply
spike.com trash Tuesday to find out how
to get your hands on simply Spike
lemonade and simply spiked Peach that's
drinks simply spike.com TR Tuesday
flavored beer naturally flavored with
other natural flavors simply spiked Co
Milwaukee Wisconsin celebrate
responsibly simply spiked and simply
spiked lemonade are registered
trademarks of the Simply Orange Juice
company I can read I can read I owe it
all to Simply
Spike wait this is actually a really
good question so there's a debate on Tik
Tok yeah so okay this is also our
Thanksgiving at Happy Thanksgiving Happy
Thanksgiving by the way also because
I've been suffer all I want to do is
complain I've been suffering so much in
this pregnancy this year the holidays
are life or death for me like I'm
clinging to them they are so important
to me I am celebrating I'm T the season
I'm listening to Christmas music already
like I need did you dress up for
Halloween no you blew it means but also
it just means you're Filipino we start
Christmas in July so you're officially
officially adopted I interrupted you so
what are you doing you're listening just
I'm celebrating I'm [__] celebrating
Christmas Christmas is going to get
awesome when you have a baby last year
last year by the way Christmas holidays
was really rough for you and you were in
a deep deep pit of depression nothing
for Christmas I literally had not I
didn't listen to a single song I didn't
see my family like you were trying to
just bypass the holidays I really was
and so I that's why I think this year
I'm like I need it and I'm not judging
you know sometimes I get in these little
[__] moods where I'm like that's
stupid like it's not for me I don't need
it but this year I [__] need it I
mean are you guys tell us what you need
from us
do you need 12 Days of Christmas I'll
give you a holiday Che this is great
speaking of giving back I am so glad I
gave back your shirt okay it was like it
was weighing on me so much and it was
like the universe was like not letting
me give it back to it was like I would
have it folded washed ready to go leave
10 minutes out can't go back I'm already
[__] late can't go back and get it so
this is what I'm saying so I could never
find one the minute I give it back to I
went to Nordstroms this is a it's one
from no it's from Urban Outfitters oh
yeah but they sell it there and it's but
it's so nice BG those are the favorite
and I couldn't find one can I tell you
where to find it um all of the ones that
I bought the oversized ones are all from
Poshmark or secondhand I've been buying
some good stuff from Poshmark I don't
this one's a Brandy Melville one it's I
kind of
it okay let's talk about this when is we
didn't care this is very important and I
need your answers okay sorry this is
holidays holiday when is the correct
time to start
Thanksgiving like
after Halloween time wise go with
Halloween what time are you eating right
okay okay well I have you don't want to
you want to have the food day you want
to have it before the day of because the
grocery store is Wild on Thanksgiving of
last minut this is not answering the
question at all no I'm I'm getting to it
thought Thanksgiving Eve you want to
have things cooking starting you want to
just smell like Thanksgiving what time
are we sitting
down 3 to oh for me and my family it's
just always dinner
Thanksgiving dinner it's 3 to 4 you can
that way because of all of the freaking
El tripan from the turkey you're going
to sleep a really like but I week after
oh yeah I'm so my Thanksgiving is so
sick coming up I'm so [__] excited
what are you guys doing I'm having a
weird Thanksgiving I know I just wait
Mrs we're just celebrating everything
well we're so we're going to New York
for the week of Thanksgiving and we're I
so terrified of holiday travel that
we're going to fly back to LA on
Thanksgiving but we're doing like a
little brunch a little mommy and daddy
brunch at a really nice place in New
York so we'll do like a full but it's
going to be early it's going to be at
noon which is not ideal you're doing a
very weird thing for a girl
that's part of the holiday season is
holiday
travel it sucks so bad you're supposed
to leave Kevin behind remember right
home alone you're supposed to you're
supposed to weren't you in that
movie the
sequel the sequel you w Kevin what was
Kevin that was his body double um no I
don't know what holiday travel is a
disaster something it's crazy you have
to surrender holidays are about
surrender yeah but you guys are season
Travelers it's it's for The non-season
Travelers where it's really a nightmare
but the airport is a nightmare not only
are we flying coach we are flying so far
back in the plane that the woman oliz
she was like I am so sorry I was like
it's fine it's
fine we're going to Jersey so Todd's
okay so this is going to be a lot of
family math Todd's older brother's wife
her parents live they bought a condo at
the beach in bamon Beach I think it's
called and so they have a condo and then
they rent this big ass house across the
street and it's got like an elevator and
they invite so it's Todd's siblings are
coming his one brother and and and his
wife the hot one hey Lexi what's up
Lexia um hey hottie no there's so many
lesma Vibes in this family hang um she
always cuts it out when I say this to
and sends it to me like what's up girls
she's so hot but anyway um so they're
going to go to her family um but they're
going to come for like the days for the
the day before but um so it's going to
be Todd's parents um Kate's parents
Wayne and Kate her his older brother
Kate's brother and sister who are
awesome and then her sister's like
really into True Crime so she like fills
you in on every like murder that's going
on she does like sleuth stuff like she's
always like so she's fun to have around
for that is like amazing she fills you
in on everything and then her brother is
like this photographer who I have a
bunch of his his work at my house and
he's like also a truck driver and he
kind of wears like girly outfits to piss
his Republican Dad off and it's like so
fun The Vibes are so high and then they
invite my parents so then my parents
come and we play like Monopoly we get
screaming matches like things go crazy
we're going to have football game on the
beach his mom got us all these crab legs
so she's cooking as Seafood the day
before and Todd's mom I've said this a
million times is my favorite restaurant
she is so good but Kate's mom's also a
great chef Kate's a great chef so it's
just like so much good food so many cool
people last year Ryan brought his
girlfriend who was she was like so hot
and so fun and so cooky so I hope
hopefully he gets a girlfriend in the
next week and can bring her but it's
just like fun they've since broken up is
what you're they broke up it's like
bring us Monica for one more week I know
but um it's just really fun and my
everyone just gets along and it's just
so fun I feel like that's how that
sounds like a really fun Thanksgiving Ty
of like
multifamily thing is like it just feels
like a party oh my God look at the
little slug you guys are the best can I
just I need to do another producer I
know I'm pregnant another producer
appreciation this is
so every little detail I cried about
them iasa I was like they're so good we
love our new producers so much we really
do it's unbelievable it's really
unbelievable so thank you guys for say
this happening on the day Julian's not
here too I know yes and to not have
Julian around is so exciting we don't
like those kinds if you know what I mean
Thanksgiving Thanksgiving has is nothing
like that at all um I didn't grow up
with Thanksgiving I have no warm
feelings towards Thanksgiving I grew up
with it and also don't have warm
feelings okay so it's not a okay I well
and then it's really just my stepdad
Roger it means a lot to him he has to
cook the turkey and then it's basically
him yelling at everyone to sit at the
table exactly when he needs everyone sat
at the table and then um he's always
like kind of half angry because he's
like dealing with a bird and then we sit
there and then we eat and then I usually
pass out on the couch and then that's it
and I really prefer it that way because
I just don't have feelings about
Thanksgiving but I love Thanksgiving
because it's the marker the next day I
go get my tree and then it's Filipino
Super Bowl right it's Christmas
Christmas is it for me it's it for my
family we go
hardan yeah it's it's there's nothing
better and truthfully Americans should
start celebrating earlier the trees are
up in the Philippines in July like if
you go to a mall in the Philippines in
July it's full-blown Christmas the
Christmas songs everything I think that
Thanksgiving let's be real is the
kickoff to Christmas yeah you can start
listening I mean I think day of
Thanksgiving you can 100 100% be playing
Christmas music well some people though
observe Christmas starting the day after
Halloween which I'm kind of doing that
this year but it really gets into high
gear observe was like a big girl word
observe that was good like I'm I'm
already working on my Christmas
playlists I'm I'm jamming out they are
really lift they lift the mood I think
so especially come I think I think you
should start it before daylight saving
time so like in the Philippines we they
call it the bur months be so once
September hits then it's like one notch
up it's like oo the burm mons are here
then it's like more trees more lights
more paroles out parole is not parole
but it's like a little like decoration
thing um but I think that's how it
should be because come daylight savings
it's so [__] depressing the sun goes
down at 4 o00 I think if you think about
it like Christmasy it's not depressing
you're like that's right if you have the
lights up already cuz it is crazy how
dark it gets it's like it really throws
your like what I've been going to bed at
like 900 p.m. really I have been passing
out that's how it should be your body
goes up and down with a s my ring is
finally winning this AA ring I got do
you guys have these what is it maybe I
should get you guys these for Christmas
if you want them they it measures your
sleep and and your period and a bunch of
stuff they're cool yeah maybe that'll be
Christmas present but um so in the
morning I check it and it tells you like
if you got enough rem or deep sleep it
might be like stressful sometimes it's
stressful but at 9:00 p.m. it always
texts me it goes you're winding down for
sleep and I'm like no [__] I'm not
winding down for sleep I'm getting ready
for work you don't know me but I'm like
maybe it knows me but it tells you if
you've like done your like work it
measures what how much you should work
out do we have the poll results for when
people so we have a couple poll results
a couple Instagram updates Kila question
Kendall Roy Hot or Not to you because
you weren't there that episode
um you know I like weird uggos but but
you thought so hard about it if it was a
yes it's not it's not on Aesthetics
alone it's a negative for me but because
I've you know watch the first season of
the show I get it um no but his it's I'm
going to go with no okay sorry I made
you do that honestly I was really like
it was the sneeze I stole the sneeze and
I forced to know it's how sad he is
against me going I am so over super sad
boys I want nothing to do with
I cannot have it not super sad not like
you know that you don't you I can't do
pessimism either anymore I need you I
can't have this I need your energy I
need you I need you to help me with this
if you say need to me I am no longer no
no no it's not that they you want them
to be sad a level of sad where they
don't know they're sad like you know
they're sad but they don't know but have
you gated the guy that goes like I had
the guy that was like I just think
you're going to be the one that like
motivates me I'm like whoa psycho
I am like I'm flying high Vibes and
everybody either has to be here or on
their way up here I am no longer I
realize my entire life has been me like
trying to tell weak men they're
strong I'm like no you little guy you're
doing great you're so stronger than all
these ones you know it's like it's like
you are good at that though but you're
also like enabling people to not be
their best self it's like rise the [__]
up and I'm not just saying men but it's
like it's just I noticed so much now
like when people are just like only
think of the most negative thing only
like and they want you to be with them
and it's like I'm not available for
complaints I can't do it anymore unless
it's Esther complaining about her
pregnancy I that feels High vibe that
does feel high Vibe how often do we talk
now it's a lot I'm not well because
anyone I already have like a
predisposition to depression and mental
illness right yes and so it's like look
I know this about myself therefore like
if someone matches my really depressive
energy it's not like we're never leaving
the house
at home together so I like the contrast
of someone being a little bit more
upbeat who wakes up in the morning wants
to get after life because that's not me
I don't want to get afterlife I want to
sit in bed and dissociate so when
someone is the opposite of that I feel
like we're balancing each other out and
honestly I could afford to teach him a
thing or two about depression and I
think you know what I mean no I think
it's like important when you have like
high energy to just keep it so that
everyone can like match it rather than
like you know like oh are we all sad
together we have more po results yeah
yeah okay so this is what Instagram
business [__] just and what I mean by
that is like those are close numbers
those are super that's very close we got
44% think Kendall Roy is hot and 56 not
I'm just going to say that's like 50/50
round it up I'll take that yeah okay
next one is the name dropping one which
which is pretty shocking we need to PLL
if people like name dropping or not like
name dropping and let's let's let Annie
have a little taste of being wrong I
don't I like being wrong I surrender to
to that Annie your take on name dropping
I love it give me all of them tell me
everything I will name drop other
people's name drops like KLA what was
your take about name dropping it's when
Annie does it it's hilarious I think who
his name dropping when Bobby or Annie do
it who gave me Olivia man gave me this
doggy bag okay that is and I've never
not told someone that but if you do it
in a way that's like you're trying to um
hide the fact like you're trying to be
cool about it like oh yeah yeah I know
that guy or I know that's gross always
like be ready to catch a name I'm
dropping are you ready I know and you
know what's funny after this episode
then Dave called me out cuz yesterday on
one of my Tik Tok lives I did a name
drop and he fully roasted me for it but
I'm like that's different I think when
you're like trying to like woo a woman
and you do it that's gross okay I was I
went on that date with that um that
singer songwriter oh that's right and he
brought up Beck and I was like I just
met Beck and he goes whoa name drop and
I was like I just met him you just
brought him up yeah that's not a name
drop I'm like what the hell are you
talking it would be crazy it would be
insane if I didn't tell him I just I had
met him the week before I was like oh my
God I know like what how tall he is and
[__] I'm going to say for the purposes
of dating and if I'm going out on a
first date with a guy and he's name
dropping it's a no for me and if they're
your friend and you're name dropping
them it's weird well I mean Olivia but
um um okay so this is what w
53% said I do it no shame 47 never it's
a turn off again 5050 that makes so much
sense for our audience to be like yeah
cuz that's how dude I'm telling you guys
I was listening to cuz Dave I caught
Dave listening to the Angela White
episode was he masturbating when I hear
the three of us talk I'm like we are all
so [__] different in every way like
of course our audience is going to be
50/50 everything like it's we're all so
different and then the last thing we
just Katie and I want to talk about is
you guys know that you have a reel that
is blowing up yeah the subway reel have
I told you guys the story about in the
first month of me and Dave dating I was
at his apartment and he was going to go
get a Subway and he took my order and I
got a foot long and he came back with a
foot long for me and a 6 in for himself
and I was like you can't do that that's
not okay hot controversy now it's so
insane and Esther's so right that it's
like but also this is one thing we fully
all agreed on which is like if a guy you
like when you ordered uh I ordered a
foot long a foot long Dave went to go
pick up the subs and he came home with a
6 in sandwich for himself and my foot
long and I had never in my life felt
lower I get it that that's confusing to
men that's fine be confus and Dave was
confused yes yes but I think it is okay
there is like differences between
genders and I think sorry it's not
always not always guys um but it is like
funny that we all feel this way and then
men feel the other way that's funny I'll
like let's get ice cream and Toad's like
no no I'm not falling for this I go come
on let's get ice cream I go I'm not
doing it I go we're getting ice cream
he's like all right fine we're getting
ice cream and then in the morning like
why'd you let me get ice cream like I
told you yeah just I think I need I need
someone to go down with a ship yeah This
ship's going down tonight I it's not
going to be my fat ass food anxiety part
of it I guess yeah and I also think
we're all self-aware that we're crazy
like that's crazy it's an insane request
but it's so it's so real I do have to
give Dave credit that like if if
literally just someone in the breeze
mentions Taco Bell he's like let's go
that's great let's go he's always down
and that is the subway is a
misrepresentation of who he truly is but
it was shocking and uncomfortable Todd
always whenever we drive by a taco B
what's that place Taco what is it called
what he always acts like he's never he's
like we should try this new restaurant
out that's actually so cute you're
hungry I can say baby voice in front of
my dog a he's so cute I do think when
you accidentally say baby voice in
public there's nothing more humiliating
but we did name one of our um geckos
goal so it's like girl and baby voice
everyone baby voice wait a second um
isn't there a thing that says like if
you do baby voice in public that that is
a sign of mental illness no like safety
trauma oh adults with baby voice is a
sign of like you know complex BTS Len I
got a lot of little reptiles and
creatures in my house a lot of baby
voices being thrown around but in public
it's so embarrassing do you do not you
and Dave don't do baby voice short to do
baby voice we do like we have our we
have our words we have a lot of like
words but the voice I need to know you
do Donut for sure
yeah thank you served by pretty wom
amazing Randy are so lucky we are oh my
f oh my God I love my dog so much him
being sick has been absolute hell he was
peeing blood no was a UTI I know but
then he all the meds are hurting him
okay shut up and eat although people
hate when we eat but whatever guys she's
pregnant we all have to eat I'm
wondering if we can have a Cheesy moment
where you guys go around and say
something nice about each other I'm
going to steal Annie's and say that I'm
so grateful oh for well let's just we
are grateful for the new producers no no
no no no it's about you guys you guys
Stella's like can you give me a
compliment no I want it's about you guys
so like what are you grateful with each
other I am so grateful for Annie's
insane Next Level sense of humor because
she will make
any topic funny
and weird and silly and not serious at
all and so I'm so grateful to have
24-hour access to that whenever I need
it and I'm
grateful obviously that Kila is a nurse
on call as well just that the three of
us are so different literally we could
not be different like our voices our
personalities how we grew up what we
believe in what we like what we dislike
we are all so different but I love that
we share this commonality of like
there's no shame there's no
embarrassment and that's the
like we're just gross and we don't care
and I I'm grateful for that top that
[__] no one's trying Esther my girl I
love my little munchkin she's so little
and so cute I think we have just known
each other a really long time and I
really appreciate how much we've kind of
gone through together and we kind of
like grew up the phases together living
in your car weird remember the little
rent I used to have and I think um you
met me when I was sharing a studio
apartment yes I was living in my car and
you were living in something the size of
a car with another person I was there
for the Dave the the Dave daving down MH
I also what I really love about you is
when [__] up [__] happens we really do
our there for each other when when we've
had some losses and stuff like that it's
been like um immediate there for each
other
safety and I love you you put up with my
nonsense I know you hate when I'm late
and it's so cute you're still my friend
and um yeah I'm proud of you I think
you're doing so many really awesome
things completely aside from growing
human you have a movie coming out you
have your set is so funny right now
everything's like really coming together
too much thank you okay never mind
you're no me Annie [__] that listen you
are the shoulders of this operation
without you we could not stand thank you
no Kila you are you shine you're like
I'm this depressed no you're like I'm I
was looking at it when I said that like
I'm like this depressed thing but no
you're a badass you're a creative
special beautiful wonderful girl you're
so dedicated you're so like loving to
people you are always there no matter
even if we're like where we're at in our
friendship you are always there you
never don't pick up um and I know that I
can ask you what's that she's a
caregiver by yeah I can ask you any
question you always have an answer oh
that's so sweet and I love like I love
how you are with your family you're so
like you're sweet I love how you are
with your dogs you're just really like
dedicated and sweet and smart and you
have thanks Annie all of the things in
the world going for you and like I like
this new boy but don't get pregnant
right now wait for you you know what I'm
going to wait for
you [__] it's too late you're too far
ahead Annie I'll wait for the cream pie
I'll I'll wait let just cream pie we'll
be like 1 two three go yeah Keele deal
deal you have to keegle to keep it in no
but I'm just saying if I want to have a
baby I'm G to keegle that [__] in I want
my baby to know I fought for
it he fought for every last drop eser um
over 10 years now I've known you and
it's just been so such a sweet little
thing to see you go through your
different phases the first time I met
you the first thing you said was do you
want to see my tits I said yes why do
you have the same origin story with
everyone you [__] [__] only you
two and then um you're just a silent
very a silent killer like you just never
really know
fart you're just this tiny little force
of
Nature and I'm I feel like sick around
you I want to throw
up I'm super grateful that when [__]
hits the fan like what Annie said like
you're a vault you have a lot of really
good advice and you're very firm and
when you get [__] done you get [__] done
and I like that you are my idol in um
asserting boundaries you're someone that
I look up to boundaries this boundaries
are wild as a people pleaser you're
someone I look up to when I need to
really you know put my foot down on
something like what would Esther do I'm
super thankful for that and just overall
our friendship and knowing that you're
just a phone call away and Annie you are
my idol When I Look For Freedom like
when I think of someone who is just so
free so just unafraid so just [__] you
to everybody when I need moments of like
to channel that that energy I always
think what would Annie do in this this
situation I love that we've all we've
always been able to you know what I mean
our phone calls is a lot of very
personal um [__] that maybe we wouldn't
tell any other person but I feel like I
can tell you anything I feel like with
the both of you there's never judgment
there's no judgment in group there's no
there's not even a Flinch when I tell
you crazy [__] there's not a Flinch
there's not a oh my God but you let us
make fun of it too it's like yeah when
we GE up like uh oh it's going get dark
oh no here she goes those are like my
favorite moments and I'm super grateful
that one random phone call three years
ago brought us to this place where we
are today and um I'm super happy we're
still blood [__] blood together one
phone call I thought it was us calling
her and being like you do a podcast with
us and I bonded over [__] blood she
wouldn't even be in the orbit if I
hadn't ship blood and bilur hadn't come
on and talk about right and's like oh
you [__] blood too I was like yeah
baby like you have to call Kila she shs
blood before insurance we needed Kila do
you remember how bad we needed Kila not
that we don't need her now but well this
is the middle of the pandemic too a bad
time to [__] blood but I'm really proud
of us that we [__] crushed the show
[__] yeah I am too and it's steady this
been like what three years crazy is
crazy and we've I'm sorry this show is a
success this show rolls
rules you guys look at our studio by the
way who came in was freaking out every
person by the way but um Jordan Jensen
was like oh my God this studio I'm like
yes this [__] studio and thank you to
our producers this this is the prettiest
set I have it's so gorgeous you guys
just absolutely crush it day to day
there you leave no stone unturned as
Annie said I always feel held in mind it
is a different energy and it's
honestly it's it's their feelings of
like do I deserve this it's crazy do I
deserve this level of attention like is
this okay I know every day I'm we come
in here I'm like can we afford this we
are we allowed to do this why are they
feeding us all the
time and like just yeah this just the
smallest gestures that you guys do are
like huge and the big gestures are even
bigger I don't know we I don't want to
get into it too much and be you know I'm
going to keep my unless Annie wants
unless Annie wants to talk no we don't
need to talk about the past we move
forward I just also want to say like I
appreciate I know that slugs have it's
tough with the change and it was like
one version and now like suddenly we
appeared but um you know everybody on
the team like loves this podcast really
believes in it is working very hard for
it but I also just like I'm so grateful
that you guys entrust us and are letting
us help you yeah all cool too by the way
everyone's cool that works like
everyone's awesome everyone's cool well
dressed good looking I'm even talking
about you guys I'm even it's just fun
like I'm always here like late just hang
out with you guys that's the B so fun
Randy just can I get chicken oh yeah
yeah I sucked out all of the spices
first so he wouldn't oh I didn't even do
that there's no spices I mean know the
breading and stuff like I Mama bro your
baby for you I don't want to give him
the oily stuff you are going to be such
a good mom though our kids are going to
be crazy though all of our kids dude
we're going to [__] our kids up and
that's come on let's be real no that's
what they say different like us however
you fix what was wrong with your
upbringing will mess them up you're over
yeah my mom was like too her mom was too
strict and then she was like what are
rules walk in the middle of the night
anywhere you want and can we say who we
are the most grateful
for Britney sp's Memoir no I know like
Bernie
Sanders our viewers our listeners we
would never be anywhere near where we
are without you we cannot do it without
you when Annie and I meet you guys at
our shows and we all met you guys at the
live show like we are so grateful that
we have found you you have found us the
the click that we it we've clicked I've
never on the street been like had
someone yell out slug or anything and
not be the coolest person I've ever seen
I know right it's always awesome people
just such good vibes boy slugs girl
slugs gay slugs all of you guys just
like it just feels like we know or and
then like that live show was such a good
Testament to that cu the audience was so
perfect and then so like every game
interact everything worked out so
perfectly by the way I ran into that
girl and she did go on a date with that
guy again oh oh my God she went out with
him again after we that was the craziest
thing we harassed a man you guys have to
come to our next live show it's things
get so good things happen um and I'm
particular particularly excited to
further connect with the mom mama slugs
out there cuz I need you I need
you I will say that's another thing and
daddy slugs yeah she's like a little
less
but but I will say yeah like everyone
everyone's so good and I love that like
when I at my shows there's like a a baby
Slug and a mama Slug and like they
there's like generational amounts we
love that we like speak to so many
different age groups and it's so cool we
love you guys love you guys so much and
I love that my sister-in-laws can watch
this we'll see you guys next week for
the beginning of Christmas oh yeah and
Merry Christmas guys because it's
happening and if you're Jewish this is
your year to be have Christmas we're
going to say Merry Christmas for the
next five episodes right yeah it's Merry
Christmas until it's the holiday season
around here until January we're still
going to say Merry Christmas then so get
used to it Merry Christmas that's one it
does get a little sad in January but
we'll we'll revisit that all right happy
holidays happy holidays and um we'll see
you next week and all a good
[Music]
night